hello welcome back
should Gotham workers be commuting where
criminals are shooting it's sad but true
the Big Apple subway ride comes with a
Chance of homicide NYPD data shows
Subway murders have skyrocketed to the
highest levels in 25 years turns out
taking the subway is now more dangerous
than directing a movie starring Alec
Baldwin
according to the post sorry killings uh
since 2020 are more than all the murders
from 2008 to 2019 combined but try
explaining that to CNN idiot and chief
Errol Lewis he's sarcastically tweeted
going home on the violent NYC Subways
rioters paralyzed with fright and he
paired it with cell phone video of a
tranquil subway station and the sweet
stylings of a jazz trumpet player you
can close your eyes and you feel like
you're in the Roaring 20s just ignore
the corpse in the corner
which is what the White House staffers
do around Joe
but Errol
soak's trumpet player makes the subway
attractive even I want to murder a jazz
trumpet player
so this adult who calls himself a
journalist takes one trip and doesn't
witness a murder and so that's proof of
safety that's like going outside at
night and thinking wow the sun must be
broken
it's like visiting Tijuana on the
donkey's day off and thinking it's a
family-friendly place
I don't know what that means but lazy
anecdotal observations about Public
Safety to right off the rise in crime
that is nothing new remember this
classic
if you watch a certain State TV and you
listen to conservative media you would
think that you know entire cities are
just you know in Broad and fights and
fires and whatever we went out had a
great dinner in New York City tonight
well he has plenty of time to go to
dinner now
[Applause]
cat as a journalist you've been a
journalist for many years doesn't it
piss you off when people just do stuff
like that like oh I'm gonna film this
and that means there's no crime or
they'll say every oh it looks good
around here or like there's no sexual
harassment here because I wasn't
sexually harassed it's this anecdotal
journalism that just is insane right yes
statistics prove otherwise and what else
proves otherwise to me that the Subway
has gotten really really really really
really disgusting yeah is that people
are actually complaining about it
because like the the standard of
behavior on the subway was never that
high right yes it never had like a
luxury Ambiance like before all this
happened I mean I'd see disgusting stuff
I saw somebody like take their pants off
and poop on the floor put their pants up
but that was like not a normal day well
I was just in that yeah yeah yeah
but nobody people at very low
expectations of what a subway ride was
going to look like so it's got to be
it's got to be really bad to be like
this is a little too much for me yeah do
you ever take the subway when you're
here no yeah that says a lot because
you're the you you would have no prob
they couldn't push you in front of
somebody I hate ducking into things yeah
you know and then I got to be ducked in
there and then there's not enough room
for me to throw somebody in there so
it's like I would I'd throw the guy he'd
bounce right back on me and be like damn
it I just threw them and he's right back
there and you know I have to wait for it
to open a sport it could be it could be
yeah sub tossing there'd be no love
involved at all the love the love would
be stopping but it just I it's like if I
went out to the Serengeti on a Wednesday
afternoon at 12 and turned my phone on
and there was nothing out there yes no
Alliance there's nothing out here and
then the guy goes look behind you yeah
you know what I'm saying like
wait a while bro yeah and if he panned
around him I'm sure he was surrounded he
made sure he had enough people to be
safe to go out there I'm sure it was
Let's Take a Shot let me step over this
homeless guy let me go around this guy
oh this scene is great yeah this is to
push that everything's fine cool then
let's take a next step further why don't
you do a special where you spend five
days in that spot and let's see what
happens exactly it's basically just
propaganda Michelle just be like hunting
for bigfoot right yeah enough is gonna
happen
I've been thinking really hard about why
people do this like why they want things
to appear better than they actually are
and then I concluded it's only when it
suits their agenda so covid I'm gonna
wear three masks but there was no it was
peaceful protests out there you know
there's no that looting and writing
that's the voice of the you know of the
oppressed and it's like wait a minute
that was looting or slavery is the
biggest stand on America which it was
but I'm going to ignore the slavery
China because I need some cheap jeans
you know so I I just I get the sense
that all of this is politically uh
driven and I'm so glad you brought the
Don Lemon clip back because this is like
a little micro Don Lemon moment exactly
exactly people don't remember if people
like he was trashing us for covering
crime two years ago a year ago I don't
know I can't remember when but it was
like and he's it's amazing if he had
actually listened to us maybe he could
have covered this stuff and some lives
could have been saved I have to ask you
because you you were you were SNL in the
90s do you feel like it's changed here
in New York you first of all I have to
tell you I was very nostalgic I was
walking around Times Square and it felt
like the early 90s because everywhere I
went I felt like I was about to get
murdered you know and it's it's a nice
feeling like wow I remember that you
know yes but it's like when you see
Anderson Cooper and he's in you know
he's reporting on the on the flood and
whatever and you pull back somebody
takes a snapshot and like cameraman's
dry yeah exactly yes
but it was a nice feeling walking around
last night yeah do you think it would do
you think uh yeah
you're not taking the subway no no of
course not but uh carries you from place
to place
three bucks is still I mean for for a
murder rate three bucks you're not
paying a lot to get murdered
that's pretty that's a pretty good deal
grab that yeah there you go
bring somebody you don't like and hope
that's how you that's how you off
somebody exactly what are you doing
later cat
oh
that's a joke that's a joke we got to
move on they loved it I know hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else